قام العمال في الكهف بتثبيت
ترايدنت الوطني لأوكرانيا على نصب تذكاري مبدع
يصور الوطن الأم يوم الأحد،
وهو تمثال فولاذي يبلغ طوله 62 مترًا
لمحارب أنثى تم بناؤه في عام
1981 خلال الحقبة السوفيتية،
ويحمل الشكل درعًا كان يحتوي في السابق على
الكتل السابقة.  شعار النبالة عليه ولكن تم
استبداله الآن،
يمكن للناس أن يدركوا أنه رمح ثلاثي الشعب
من جميع الجوانب، فهو ليس صغيرًا جدًا
وليس كبيرًا جدًا وليس سميكًا جدًا وليس
نحيفًا جدًا، إنه الوسط الذهبي ومع ذلك فإن رمح
ثلاثي الشعب ليس متوسطًا فهو يترك علامة
دائمة  الانطباع بأنه
رمزنا الوطني، رمز انتصارنا، إن
تحرك أكيف لاستبدال الرمز هو
محاولة للتخلص من ذكريات
الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق الذي صعدت أوكرانيا
منذ الغزو الروسي